sm7s are estimates sm7 B's yeah I think
why industry standard I know they're way
overpriced but it's like hey
this is how much I'm dedicated to the
art of podcasting dude I'll uh
you're gonna trip the [ __ ] out whenever
I tell you how much I bought mine for
you paid over market price for them
you would be surprised when I paid for
it it probably would be like like if you
bought
eight bags of these it would be cheaper
than that
these are that expensive I'm gambling it
it's like 80 bucks they're like 10 bucks
a bag all right yeah you could have got
two of these for what I paid oh you paid
a little bit for it not a lot yeah yeah
oh nice
yeah so like
Sam and I started like like a side
content thing that we're still shooting
episodes for before we released them you
put it right by your mouth
it's live right now oh we're going yeah
hello hello
yeah it's public we got two concurrent
viewers what's up it's live
um but yeah so you bought them for cheap
is it because like you knew a guy not at
all so like uh what we do is uh we roll
around to like different pawn shops and
like music shops and like we see like
what's in there and like what's usable
gear so like uh we'll go look for like
you know decent guitar amps they're like
uh like vintage pedals or you know just
good deals on [ __ ] that you could like
buy that day and take just do it like
every month or every week we started
doing it like we was trying to shoot
them like every every week but it's like
with us gigging and [ __ ] and then
everybody having everything else on so
it's like a TV show idea yeah but like
really short real digestible you know
what I mean like edited down into
probably like six to like 12 minutes
yeah you know Gary vaynerchuk does that
but with garage sales
he goes to garage sales and he's like
look I got this Lego for two bucks but
it's worth 10 bucks
and he makes like eight dollars at a
time now if I do this ten thousand times
he needs to hire people straight up so
like how did you uh find the sure sm7bs
for so cheap and are you worried about
damage that you can't see no dude we
actually used it the other day to uh to
shoot some content over at The White
Buffalo room and uh like it's fine yeah
so like I hit this pawn shop off of will
Cannon like right behind that HEB off 35
South
um
it's on like the right hand side and
there's like a Cash Pawn America and uh
yeah so I went over there and uh like I
was just looking around in there and
like sometimes you'll see like some like
some like Mexican Fender strats or like
tellys or something like that or like
some like uh boss metals on pedals or
whatever but like I just saw like an
sm7b microphone and I looked at the
price tag on it was like holy [ __ ] and
like walked over there it's like yo can
I like there's like 400 bucks yeah dude
and I paid I think like 38 bucks for it
they didn't know what they had son and
that never happens like I've gotten in
like there's still guitars that are in
pawn shops right now that I would have
if they would like just remember that
they're a [ __ ] pawn shop like they're
like
I know what I got type situation yeah
like I don't know sometimes they're like
marked up and used I don't know it's
weird
mentality yeah
yeah I mean uh pawn shops that's what
America's breeding ground America's
backbone yeah it's the uh Estuary where
you know poorer people meet other poor
people dude for some people it's a bank
yeah you know you can like go there and
trade in everything and then buy it
again and trade it again
it's a vicious cycle out here yeah I
mean it is one way to do it but there is
a lot of transaction fees in middlemen
involved
it is dude and like if you're not on
your [ __ ] like you uh you get charged
like the other day I was buying a guitar
and uh I was paying it off in chunks or
whatever and uh
I took like two or three weeks off like
from paying it off because I had paired
who paid like a shitload of it down like
only it was like I think less than 100
bucks
and I just so happened to go meet up
with Sam
and uh we were smoking over at Buzz Mill
and then uh went over to that pawn shop
and uh I saw it for sale and I was like
hey what the [ __ ] like am I buying that
and they're like oh yeah glad you came
in blah blah blah and like I ended up
having to pay like a restocking fee for
it but I paid like an extra 100 bucks
but
long story short [ __ ] paying off
quick you know so you this was a guitar
that you were gonna buy or that I did
end up buying like I did I didn't end up
getting it but like
oh but you sold it and then you bought
it back no I just I saw it it was a good
deal so like I was just paying it off
like playing gigs or whatever and we had
like two weeks off so I was just
chilling
and I ended up going back in just to go
like uh make a payment on it and I saw
that they'd put it for sale again I was
like what the [ __ ] like I only owed like
100 bucks on it so you would just go
there borrow it then give it back to
them no it stayed there like I was just
buying it and like you go there and you
keep paying it off so you didn't even
have it no so I went there to go like
pay it off and like it was for sale
again I was like what the [ __ ] is this
why would you have to pay a restocking
fee
because it's a pawn shop I don't know
because they were like yeah yeah
we were gonna make more money exactly
that's crazy man I want to trust pawn
shops but that's cool that you can find
deals like that every night's like a TV
show
called Pawn Stars
it is man
that's cool but that's from the pond
owners side pond store owner side right
like the uh
like going in there and shopping for it
that'd be like more for the customer's
perspective and it's definitely like
Niche stuff like we're not just going
there and like oh this is like some
heirloom Silver Spoon set like we're
looking for [ __ ] they like oh [ __ ] like
my Aunt blue we're on the road like I
need something I can play like yo this
will get you through the gig like you
know that day or something you know yeah
and you know what your instruments are
and you know like the industry so you
know like what a good product is you're
not going in there buying blind right
and like the worst of [ __ ] that they
have they're kind of the better almost
you know it's kind of funnier yeah
because it's been through more it's
survived the test of time right or it's
just complete garbage it's just like
what the heck sounds yeah definitely
so uh are you really keen on sounds like
you walk down the street you hear like a
bell tingle and you're like oh that
could be a good noise to incorporate
into the noise Factory that is my job
um man to be honest like I've always got
like this like band that's like playing
in my head most of the time like in my
riding process like I'll have like a
riff or like a melody or something like
that and uh
like I'll have to like tune that out to
kind of like do other stuff but like I'm
really not painted like Sam and Cole
would be more like those guys like you
could honk your horn and you'd be like
oh that's in the key of whatever you
know what I mean it's in the key of Love
definitely with that dude
that's cool that's what I think
musicians do but I'm sure they're just
normal people too oh yeah definitely
like um that's also like I feel like
that's kind of like what brings us all
together like we all have like our [ __ ]
that's like we're good at and like not
everybody's like uh like ego driven you
know what I mean we all kind of bring
some [ __ ] to the table yeah I mean the
we're in an industry where there's like
Superstars but then to get to that point
you have to sort of realize the larger
picture and like you know like you can't
just be the sole person that's great at
everything you need everyone
contributing and if you think like uh
Winner Takes all mentality I think it's
bad for the art
definitely well it's like [ __ ] like
knowing what you're good at it's like
[ __ ] the heck to life like [ __ ]
like networking and like you know like
I have like good Melodies and like or
maybe like I'm decent at riding riffs
and I write good songs and then whenever
I bring them to the band they get better
yeah you know so like we're social
animals correct and so like you should
like anybody who's like tries to like be
like the smartest person in the room or
like with me like I try and be the worst
musician in the band that not like I'm
trying to do my best you know what I
mean I'm the best person in the room if
I'm the best [ __ ] player in my group
then you're not learning that sucks yeah
yeah
So like
um you know you want to grind because
you want to [ __ ] be good at what
you're doing but also you want to be
surrounded by murderers yeah
yeah otherwise you're not developing and
getting better right stagnating and if
you're just good at like just being the
smartest person in the room you're good
at ignoring human contribution you're
just used to being like Oh I don't need
you I don't need you you're just getting
good at like dismissing these sources of
energy that you could use
you know it's like a power plant every
person is so much energy and power that
they've lived however 30 years
and you could take all that experience
in without having to live their life and
if you can do that you can gain 30 60 90
years of experience
and if you just leave that potential
energy on the table then you're not
effective or efficient and it's also
makes you a miserable person
yeah man I think about all the the
energy that you're saving like not
[ __ ] worrying about stuff that you're
not good at you know like being
confident enough and humble enough to
like somebody you know like a comedian
or somebody who wants to like ask you to
help them punch up a joke or something
is able to say like all right I know I
can put my pride aside or my ego aside
and ask Hans to help me be better you
know what I mean so it's like kind of
like the same thing like like in music
and [ __ ] like that like you know like
[ __ ] utilize like you said like you
can get 30 years of experience from
somebody from their experience and you
know being willing to learn from them
without having to live it yourself so
it's like
um yeah definitely that's like a
thousand percent the the game I'm
running right now you know yeah and
music is so uh
uh transmissible too
because it's like so you can get it in
an instant oh this is how this guy feels
and you can transmit emotional knowledge
powerfully
uh and you're always you know
in that environment the comedy I think
is different I think it's more like left
brain sort of like technically that
makes sense
um it doesn't make sense a lot more I
think which is like a good thing and a
bad thing because it's not as like
powerful but I think like once it does
work its way in there it's like a
permanent fixture because you're like oh
this is how logic works and thought
works
but yeah I like the the both of them I
mean I think comedy is very like left
brain and I feel like music is very it
feels better than comedy right well it's
like um like I don't know if everybody
every musician feels like me or like
front man I guess but it's like there's
like three minutes you know or something
total like in like the set we're like
I'm not playing music and I'm talking to
the crowd and stuff and like if you're
not dialed then like you wish that you
could kill like a comedian in those
times you know what I mean and like I've
seen musicians just eat [ __ ] and there's
between songs like all right hurry up
that's what I'm gonna do well too where
they capture the moment sometimes you're
on dude you know and like you really
connect with the crowd and that's
whenever like those kind of moments
happen but sometimes dude like you're
playing this dog [ __ ] gig and like you
the music's not connecting with them or
something and like neither are your
jokes between them
you know it's like yeah well that's a
unique experience because musicians do
comedy and music but comedians usually
just do they don't do music at all they
can just focus on the comedy so you're
bombing on two different art forms it's
totally just sucking oh yeah definitely
yeah it's like you can bomb twice I
guess both sides getting
[ __ ] in the ass and the mouth right
well I'd much rather go down swinging
trying to be the funny guy than trying
to be some like fake ass like
song like you know the songwriters yeah
dude because that's so not me like a lot
of people like I don't know I guess like
I've met
I don't I guess like there's like a lot
of songwriters out there that are like
[ __ ] they think that they're Mark
Twain or something like that you know
and it's like a guy like relax yeah you
know and like it's not relatable it's
hard to enjoy right and like uh you know
I don't have like this like real gnarly
like songwriting process and like what I
write and record and play is like more
or less what I like to listen to so I
just try and like try and capture that
band in my head and get it out as best
as I can and like
um you know good time feeling music and
like stuff like that so it's also it's
like am I not my personality like taking
myself too serious to like have that
kind of ego I guess or something like
that yeah you know I mean that's hard to
watch with someone in yours in your
field with ego
it is man it's the worst because they
haven't [ __ ] been like [ __ ] up yet
like
stuff's gone right for them for a minute
or something and they just haven't been
[ __ ] on yet yeah you know because like
once you like you know you eat the [ __ ]
sandwich a few times and like you
develop like a real thick skin and
you're like all right like you can start
navigating these Waters and like you
learn how to [ __ ] you know keep
moving forward and sometimes you move
laterally but you're still making moves
and stuff but it's like sometimes you
meet people that haven't like been
punched in the face by reality and like
sometimes it's shattering for them
whenever it happens and they quit and it
never happened like they you know don't
learn from it and uh
some people are really good at being
delusional that's their skill it's like
I'm the best and nothing can ever
convince me otherwise right it was just
fun at times but it's like not my
strategy you almost need a a like a
[ __ ] little bit of that but you need
more like [ __ ] like work ethic with
that you know what I mean like yeah you
ride a shitload and like I know that
because I listen to other podcasts and I
hear about how much you write you know
what I mean and so like [ __ ] your
willingness to [ __ ] write and like
work real hard coupled with [ __ ] a
bit of ego is a [ __ ] a dangerous
combination it's healthy yeah you know
what I mean a little bit of food
coloring you've dropping some ego and it
just [ __ ] the whole thing is it's
colorful the healthy confidence you know
it's not you being like a piece of [ __ ]
it's wanted you know what I mean like
you can be humble and say like oh no you
know like I'm not that but like in the
in here you know you can you you can be
that guy you know yeah you need that or
else you become like your cook Asian
and then you just don't have any
confidence and you're like oh yes
everyone else is better and then the
individual isn't incentivized to create
awesome [ __ ] right it's like uh what's
also it's like you know like sometimes
you're in like 100 degree moments and
like you're [ __ ] like you're about to
go play like a really big gig for
instance like in Arena show with you and
sometimes you got to have that internal
dialogue and be like yo it's time to go
like
I'm not you know I'm here a guy here
like let's [ __ ] go like this is what
I do is I have moments where I have to
be present and that's the job and you
know if you don't enjoy it then
like there's plenty of other jobs but I
mean there is like this is what I've
learned to enjoy more than anything else
so why wouldn't you enjoy it
everything's set up for you to enjoy it
um and then it's just up to yourself
whether you choose to accept Joy in that
moment and if you're like no I don't
deserve this then you're going to
self-sabotage in some way right yeah you
see a lot of self-sabotaging like
sometimes like my [ __ ] dad's funny he
used to call it cell shaft syndrome
because you're shafting yourself because
you're [ __ ] yourself you know what I
mean yeah and so like uh yeah there's
like a lot of that man and so like you
know being able to to like mature to the
work like like your writing process or
like you know making sure that you're
you're [ __ ] doing that stuff like
that other stuff comes easy whenever
it's time to call on that yeah call on
yourself to stand up to the [ __ ]
moment like yeah yeah I practiced right
I have this wealth of uh you know hours
behind me you got the Reps on stage
before you flew out to go do that and
then it's not even about ego it's just
about physics and this is how the
process works and if it doesn't work for
me then it's not going to work for
anyone correct so then I don't even have
to be like I'm the best and I have a
giant [ __ ] and then I'm gonna go up
there and swing it I can just be like
this is
How the Universe Works the power of the
universe runs through me no yeah
definitely it's like something about
like getting in that flow State and like
well I mean it's also it's like you know
the universe like like the universe or
God or whoever you're talking to at
night like puts people in your life or
puts stuff in your life stuff happens
for a reason you know or stuff doesn't
happen for a reason so like you get
given an opportunity and you don't do
the work and you don't show up and you
[ __ ] bomb well then yeah man like
[ __ ] grind like get back to it you
know what I mean and like whenever
you're given those opportunities because
you work so hard you [ __ ] knock them
out of the park so whenever you do meet
people like Tony he's like oh [ __ ] that
comedian you know Hans we drew his name
for the first time up here and he
[ __ ] killed like what was that and
like you get to go again you know what I
mean and so it's like the more then
you're developing your own momentum and
then Tony starts talking to other people
or like you know whoever club Owners are
talking about you to other club Owners
and or Festival buyers and you know
podcasters and it kind of gets out there
so it's like all kind of revolves around
you know I guess like
like you said like managing the you know
the ego and like willingness to learn
and work you know yeah and then other
people that do that can recognize it in
you be like oh this guy's a guy that
works hard because he takes the correct
amount of Joy from each set he takes the
correct amount of sadness
it's a shame yeah he's not just doing it
just so that he can just be like oh I
did it he's doing it so the next one
will be better and once you're in that
zone and anything else looks disgusting
and inauthentic right well it's like
also like like you said like I mean like
I had a [ __ ] whenever I graduated I
worked for a uh like a sales company and
uh like that [ __ ] [ __ ] sucked dude
and like I was making other people
[ __ ] loaded and like
I wasn't getting rich and I was playing
less gigs and like at that point I was
like already touring and opening for
like really big bands
um you know I guess per se in like the
Texas scene but like
um you know that was like a step back
for me dude and I was like [ __ ] I'm in
hell right now I gotta figure out how I
can like well that's most people's lives
that's what I can't [ __ ] figure out
they're on the highways right now
driving with that life you gotta figure
out what the [ __ ] you like to do and
figure out how to make money doing it
it's not set up for you to do that it's
not so if you can get horny and
desperate marry the first girl you see
pop out babies get diabetes have the
health insurance from the company you're
stuck in and then you just have to cope
with doing something you hate for the
rest of your life and that's that's the
skill that most people are monetizing
well I think it's also it's like growing
up like you know you kind of know from
like a young young age like you're
either like cutting up in class or like
you know like [ __ ] around and it's
like kind of because you always kind of
knew like I'll be all right I'll figure
out [ __ ] something like this doesn't
matter and like yeah this is not
relevant or correlates yeah just like
not interested you know what I mean like
the people that did [ __ ] ball out and
like kill it and that like not all of
it's bad you know some of them are
doctors some of them are lawyers some of
them are [ __ ] that's how the system
should work ideally right the people
that don't [ __ ] rise to the occasion
and actually know what the [ __ ] they
want to do they should be a class for
Honky Tonk it should be a class for you
know comedy
art a fine arts class yeah but what do
we we have like arithm I mean you need
arithmetic but it's like no nothing is
about a job this is just like a
secondary skill that then Loosely
correlates with a job like it's we're
not being trained for any job and people
kids can sense that if we didn't treat
it like a job though we would just be
sitting around saying you're a comedian
and saying I'm a songwriter though yeah
you know like you make your own wheels
turn and I make my own wheels turn and
like we're well it's good yeah it's good
to have the umph exactly so like the
moment that I figured out that I could
take everything from like that [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass sales job I had
and apply it to music you know I was
cold calling music venues then and at
that point I'd been cold calling like
[ __ ] thousands of small businesses
and trying to sell them [ __ ] social
online services so I developed a real
thick skin you know I mean and at that
point I had done enough reps where I had
a product and I was you know decent so I
was able to get gigs and I was like you
know this is basically going to be the
grind and now it's trying to figure out
how to like start knocking off like
goals I want to do with music and like
um
so that's you know kind of been the game
plan yeah so like just yeah just
approaching it like a job and using the
same energy that you had for sales but
for something that you like doing now
right well it's like you know I'm not
already a functioning blown up
individual that's making a lot of money
so like I'm doing fine right now I'm
doing great but in the scheme of like
let's say like a really big like Talent
buyer you know what I mean like you're
talking like you know somebody like you
know with really big like a big falling
like Garth Brooks or something like that
you know I'm not there yet but it's like
you know I believe in myself that I
could get to be you know not as big as
Garth Brooks clearly he's [ __ ] huge
but like you know I could say that's the
that's the goal you know I want to sell
a shitload of tickets yeah and I want to
make great music that I enjoy to listen
to and uh but like what I'm getting at
is that like you know at some point you
got to do this [ __ ] for yourself until
somebody else wants to do it for you you
know so I took it took time to learn how
to become a really good booking agent
and like book my own [ __ ] gigs and
like make all these own opportunities
happen until like you know now we're
starting to to make a little noise and
we're starting to get out and like tour
and sell out shows
and um you know now we're starting to
have those conversations with with some
of those entities and like
um you know it took me [ __ ] doing it
for myself for a long [ __ ] time
before somebody else started approaching
me about doing it for me yeah you know
and so um
that's kind of like the
the motivation behind it you know yeah
because it's not directly related to the
art form but it is energy and work that
you can put into it
well it's like it's it's you know just
like just like your your joke writing
and stuff like that you get into
everything you get everything that you
put into whatever you're doing so like I
sent like probably like 120 emails last
week booking like shows from April
through May from like we're going on a
run
um the first of May up through like
Nashville Alabama and the Carolinas
um and I'll announce those dates uh on
Thursday
but um you know I sent like 135 emails
between like them like going out on on
that little tour the little run and then
uh like booking throughout Texas like
from my
March through you know June and like a
only [ __ ] maybe like
30 of those might get back to me yeah
you know and like maybe
six of those
might come through and I might close
like four or five of them but I could
keep hitting those back up you know what
I mean and like start like a sales
process with them and keep the calendar
full so that's kind of like the uh the
process and if I was waiting for anybody
else to do that I'd be [ __ ] waiting
around to die yeah you know it's so easy
to do now too with the internet back
before the internet you'd have to get
yellow pages from a Akron dude and then
just call up bars but now like you can
see the reviews and other bands that
have been there and then right well then
I like to do is like go to like a
comedian that I'm jealous of and then I
just uh go to all the shows that he's
booked on and just ask hey can I try to
get that the show schedule of someone
that I respect and that I you know want
to be like oh certainly like I book
tours like that like I'll see I got
touring and he's out of state and I'm
kind of like
you know I'll probably show up in a
Spotify playlist that he's on you know
like it makes perfect sense that I
should play there
I'll screenshot the whole tour you know
I'll email every single [ __ ] venue
and try and plan that same thing yeah
you know sort of like stealing but not
really not at all it's you know you're
he's doing the Dirty Work
and you're just they did the heavy
lifting yeah you know you already vetted
it and then they can when you pop up
with a new venue you can put that on
your show schedule and then other people
right and use that as a Bible well like
uh I've got like a big Excel spreadsheet
that I put together like over the years
that like I'll actively send to like
musicians like you know if I go if I
bump into them or they hit me up online
and they're trying to like book shows or
whatever yeah
yeah dude like here like have at it you
know what I mean that I did well it you
can't really think like that though
because it's like uh you know it's like
a pie mentality and you always be like
like if you're the amount of success
that you have doesn't make me any less
or more of like yeah I'm not saying it's
a bad thing I'm saying like you're
generous and that you do that because
that's like a lot of work they don't
have to do now and then they can focus
on what they like right but it's like
anybody who has that that different
mentality where it's like a you know
like no I don't want you playing these
gigs because I don't want you to get you
know there's like a there's like a
debate in hunting about your spots like
should you Reveal Your Response or do
you want to keep it secret it's like
we'll buy some [ __ ] land dude
yeah well you can't always buy all the
best hunting spots you go to dude
there's plenty of great spots for sale
like here in Texas for sure but like in
Missouri and like fishing spots and
stuff like that I guess it's like it's a
anecdotal for it to be like applied but
I feel like in the spirit of like
the universe and Karma and all that
other [ __ ] like the more you give
the more you get man so like not always
no sometimes you get [ __ ] burned dude
sometimes you tell everyone about a spot
and then it's ruined right or you like
refer somebody to a gig somebody hit you
up for one you're like all right yeah I
got one here like you send them over
there and they [ __ ] up yeah that's the
worst does that ever happen with you no
really right on dude I don't really help
a lot of people oh okay okay I didn't
mean to be like I want to right hit him
up I I've maybe I do in different ways
but yeah I I want to do it more I want
to be more generous right what do you
think about giving to the homeless
man I tell you I was a little late I got
caught up at the corner of 35 and Chavez
and I was getting the windows washed uh
and eventually or non-consensual I mean
it's always non-consensual but they did
a great job
you know yeah and uh you know I gave him
what I had uh which happened to be like
a couple hundred bucks but no way no
[ __ ] no dude all that money from the
sure sm7bs that you got for cheap on the
cheaper probably stolen matter of fact
things are hot yeah I know who what band
has been broken into recently they
probably want that dude uh Paul cauthen
actually got his [ __ ] stolen in Dallas
so whoever did that [ __ ] you if you're
watching
yeah how dare you right yeah real [ __ ]
up our Friday we were gonna go open for
him in Houston and uh got a hold of his
manager and they told us uh yeah all
their [ __ ] was gone all their
instruments all their merch so y'all go
buy some more Paul cauth and [ __ ] online
musicians helping out thieves all over
the country since dude
yeah I mean it's always a big Target
well especially with us like uh oh with
like our vans wrapped you know so I'm
always like wondering if like cops you
know it's probably like cops and [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah it sucks dude sometimes it's
[ __ ] wild like uh we were playing
this Steakhouse out in this oil patch
town in Kennedy
and uh there's just like a like a bunch
of like uh
like
I guess like young Roughnecks you know
what I mean like they're not old enough
to like classic country music but
they're young enough to say they like
country yeah so they [ __ ] got like
the shitty mullets and the hey dude
shoes and [ __ ] like
asking us to asking us to play some
[ __ ] whack [ __ ] songs
and uh yeah dude just like you think
things are gonna come to fist cuffs you
know they're just like man these people
[ __ ] suck this gig sucks
I saw a movie yesterday called the menu
because it was out dude on the Internet
it's like mid-summer but digest it's
like mid-summer but yeah not as foreign
it's like oh this is a world I'm
familiar with and like after you like
you know
I'm locking that door and nobody else is
leaving
the only big guys that were there that
were like kind of like the henchmen
there wasn't that many of them yeah you
know what I mean and like the rest of
them are chefs dude like what the [ __ ]
like you start punching them in the face
I don't know man uh they were all older
I mean you're very young and strong but
yeah a lot of them were like not and
they're not cohesive they don't know
each other they're not friends they got
tricked they're in a weird mind State I
mean I don't know how I would act well
they're all gonna die they've all got
this [ __ ] money they know they're
gonna exactly so like that's also it's
like I feel like if you started like
introducing pain to them if that would
almost wake them up out of the trance
and like I'm getting the [ __ ] out of
here well they did try you know then the
chefs found them the cooks right anyways
what that movie is about is like how
this guy hates his audience yeah with
definitely was his customers I totally
kind of vibed with that now that you're
like uh like picking up on that because
there's been so many [ __ ] [ __ ] gigs
yeah we're like well I think it's
because everyone is doing something they
don't want to do for a living trapped
with a woman that was hot 20 years ago
and popping out babies that you know are
not genetically Superior
[Laughter]
brought to you by our friends at crispr
kids
but no I think it's everyone's miserable
and if everyone was in a better mood I
think art would be better audiences
would be better there'd be better
Rapport but I think like I mean I'm I
love the audience that I have now
because this is a very cream of the crop
audience it took [ __ ] you getting
through the goddamn trenches to get
there though I've seen all the other
audiences on the way to this audience
exactly and it's not pretty it makes you
appreciate those those audiences you
know what I mean it also makes you want
to work harder to like kind of like uh
because there are some times you show up
to a gig and you're like wow this is
going to be some [ __ ] and then even
though it's not like some big music hall
or some big Festival
and like uh you know it might just be
like a quaint hole in the wall the
crowd's [ __ ] into it and somehow you
[ __ ] did it and like you [ __ ] made
a little bit of money that night you
[ __ ] connected with some people and
you [ __ ] overcame some [ __ ] you
know what I mean yeah that's the best
when it's like a tough audience but you
win them over
but yeah I mean if these people were
more emotionally mature and maybe they
weren't just like sitting around all day
waiting for the clock to hit five right
then sitting around listening to their
husband or wife that they hate like this
is like not a very rich spectrum of
emotion and then like I go up there and
I talk about like Jews or something and
they're like oh foreign
people but there's a there's a very
large amount of people that like where
that nine to five that pain gives them
that much more like
like that much more you know what I mean
makes them appreciate it that much more
so they listen to you on the way to
their job they listen to you while
they're [ __ ] grinding they listen to
you on the way home they come out to the
show and they take it in you know and
like but then you do have those [ __ ]
people that don't like joy that yeah
they go to a comedy show and they just
chill are you waving to the cat I am
dude
uh but yeah I don't mean to talk [ __ ]
about it like some of them are great
audience members but I would rather have
like smart intelligent happy content
people oh my God
he's not on the stream now but yeah
that's ideally you know the best she
loves water like she'll drink out of
here she like kolaches
but yeah I mean I uh I yeah this is all
theoretical it's not like there's
another
healthy Society to compare it to but
it's not like Liberals are the best
audience to perform for
and they're like you know upper middle
class chilling uh they're happy and
content but they're still like miserable
so it's like is it because they live in
a society that's [ __ ] up and they're
the only ones that are living correctly
and they're it's not very strong energy
to be content and happy so they're
easily influenced by poverty and Trauma
negativity from most of the other
population or is it like just being
contented happy as a dead end and we
should
just like not try to
limit suffering because it'll just turn
you into a liberal
like I think they're like [ __ ]
like there's like Renaissance after
[ __ ] really hard times like you need
[ __ ] hard times they [ __ ] it makes
hard people but it also makes [ __ ]
really artistic people like like art
thrives like I don't the history just
kind of shows it but like
like you're almost kind of like need
those kicks in the [ __ ] nuts and like
those interactions with those shitty
[ __ ] people for you to like really
grow and appreciate and like learn how
to like uh like Channel those kind of
people and like into your brand and like
growing yourself like that kind of way
you know and like
um
I guess kind of like really like leaning
into like the yin and the Yang I guess
of it all
and that could be like the uh I mean
isn't there enough suffering without
having to like not give people health
care dude did you turn off the comments
and like your your section or something
like no who's I mean I'm not like
talking about right now but it's like
I guess like I don't know like who's
like what was like your worst like
interaction coming up as like a comedian
like between like either like a fellow
cook comic a venue owner or like a uh
like somebody in the crowd obviously you
get heckled even at the highest level so
it's like kind of
well the most recent one I can think of
is like I did a headlining gig and I was
hanging out with my feature and his
family like the guy that featured for me
and this old
white man not that that's important but
he was old and white and a man he was a
cracker yeah he goes up to the feature
and he goes great job really loved you
you were amazing and he goes to me it's
like
so how did you come up with a bit about
liberals like and it was just like sort
of like implying that he liked the
feature but better than me right and not
being very subtle about it oh okay so
like he got really slightly he got
really hurt because he felt like uh you
talked about him
no because he was liberal right no he
was I think I don't think he was liberal
okay but he was just asking me like uh
he wasn't complimenting me okay
conspicuously compliments he's like
yeah he's kind of picking apart yourself
instead of just giving you roses like
you did your future act yeah yeah that
was annoying there's just like little
things like that he was a plant your
future act came to go do that to you
yeah it's just like he's he thinks his
opinion's really important and like I
need to know it yeah that he liked
someone else better than me
and it's just like I'm sorry that I had
a bad set you know sometimes it goes
better than that but honestly like I'm
sorry like you should even if you hated
it you shouldn't go up to someone whose
art that you hated and be like hey this
guy is better than you right like what
is the point of that no definitely it's
like uh there's no like he felt entitled
enough to [ __ ] like come up and tell
you that which just kind of like tells
you like I don't know the guy's probably
a little off his rocker he was a little
weird you get a lot of weird [ __ ]
people that hang around that don't
really do they're not Comics or they're
not musicians and they're not like you
know but they hang around and you know
like they're very opinionated sometimes
and like sometimes it's like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about like well
especially with music because everyone
yeah everyone's got a plan yeah like
everyone's you know like oh you should
go do American Idol or you should go do
uh yeah The Voice or whatever the [ __ ]
it's like dude
man
no that's all it took right yeah no [ __ ]
I would have done that along with that
well actually dude there's a bunch of
people that go in there and lose and
like tour it's like what the [ __ ] why
not you know yeah you get locked into a
crazy contract though for a minute is
the word uh
so yeah really the nicest place to work
no this guy suck yeah well I mean it's
crazy how many people can tour and don't
like if you've been on anything anywhere
people will come out to see it right
um because I guess people are bored like
there is a lot of like a slight little
Tick Tock right well it's like also it's
like people need entertainment you know
what I mean like people are looking for
[ __ ] to do like even in a big ass
[ __ ] City like Austin when there's
[ __ ] like I don't know three or four
million people in the greater area like
between Buda and let's say like Round
Rock or some [ __ ] you know like there's
a [ __ ] load of people and there's a lot
of [ __ ] like people even if like there's
a big ass concert going on at the Moody
Theater there's still a bunch of people
that are trying to find people like you
and me to go watch yeah you know what I
mean yeah we need it our brains are the
biggest muscle and we need it to be
stimulated or it's gonna atrophy right
well and it's also it's like people get
[ __ ] bored like we were [ __ ] stuck
inside for the longest time and like I
don't know what it is right now but dude
like the wells run dry like Netflix like
there's nothing but like the murder docs
are okay but it [ __ ] sucks Netflix is
negative clean it up Jeffrey Dahmer yeah
like
they're they're coming with some B [ __ ]
some some mids a lot of mids coming
through Netflix yeah it's weird I
thought it'd be better
um yeah I remember Netflix would be like
fun to I'm I'm mostly on YouTube now I'm
mostly on small creators I thought it
was so [ __ ] weird because my niece
and nephew like my brother's like I
don't know did they watch YouTube like
they like you know we had like cartoons
and stuff growing up and uh it's all
produced I can't watch anything produced
I need something real yeah yeah so like
even like the like the Lo-Fi like like
the kids just playing with toys and [ __ ]
like that's what they're into when
they're younger and now they kind of
watch content creators because I think
they can like understand it and stuff
well it's interesting to see what
exactly kids are interested in because
they're just pure this is how they're
born they're interested in people in
boxing [ __ ]
they're into we missed it dude because
there's people in a fight Frank's bag
right now doing that yeah just buying
there's a few of those guys that have
good prank uh channels like yeah Danny
Mullen you uh he does some pretty crazy
[ __ ] it's an art form dude yeah well
like uh yeah he somehow gets away for
the most part like he gets arrested and
like I think I've seen him like into
something
which ones bad prank like people that
are bad they go to the hood and try to
do pranks you know it's a prank bro I'm
just getting shot at right yeah they
just have no love for people they're
just using them for content and it's
just right yeah this isn't coming from a
good place is like it's like any other
art form and it's you're dealing with
people out in public right which is
unpredictable so you have to really
[ __ ] have your heart in the right
place well it's like you know I think
kind of like jackass and uh like the
wild boys kind of like they had some
prank [ __ ] that they were doing like in
the midst of their stunts and stuff or
they're just really shock [ __ ] people
yeah like the guy in the trunk with all
duct taped in his underwear yeah just
busted out or like Knoxville going into
the weight room with the [ __ ] dildo
and his sweatpants or whatever you know
so like I think kids like saw that and
then the YouTube era or whatever like
was like starting to Bubble like just
after that so like people were doing
pranks online and the shit's like funny
as hell but like sometimes like whenever
they're like you know like
got like a 4k camera filming themselves
given they're giving like a bum like a
sandwich in like a dollar or something
or like even if it's like a hundred or a
thousand bucks it's like dude like
[ __ ] you could have just gone and
done that and you didn't have to like
try and like you know make sure [ __ ]
the YouTube good enough content if
giving people ten dollars was like they
did a flip and they were like a seal now
if you would have pooped on that ten
dollars then gave it to the guy dude oh
[ __ ] dude like a moral conundrum does he
take it oh he takes it every time ten
dollars yeah brother maybe that's like I
think they throw that straight in their
pocket without looking at it
yeah it just matches the rest of their
smell that day
I mean homelessness is really optional
and I think we should like
take money out of everyone's pocket be
like hey we're gonna
put these people in homes
through your taxes yeah I mean you could
put them in homes and [ __ ] like that but
like there's a lot of them out there
that just like don't [ __ ] with that yeah
I mean I'm sure they exist but I think a
larger portion of these people just need
to get on their feet a thousand percent
and they're they're you know they're out
there and sometimes they get into the
system that works so there's not there's
a [ __ ] broken one here in Austin but
sometimes you hear of like you know
people that get out of homelessness and
stuff like that but for I think a lot of
it is like mental [ __ ] like mental
health and like there's a lot of really
sick people that they don't there's no
facilities to take care of them you know
and they don't have homes now and they
don't have homes and so they're [ __ ]
like yeah like they're obviously like
mentally broken and then like what
happened that they got mentally broken
they were probably coming from a broken
home because of our judicial criminal
you know like process right and also
like maybe predisposed to mental illness
or whatever it may be either way they're
not and then they have economic
hardships on top of that correct so if
you take out the economic hardships you
get rid of like you know at least half
send it back you create rain send it
back
I'm just kidding
Ukraine I mean whatever I don't know how
the budget works if we need to send
money to Ukraine it's not like if we
didn't send money to you we still
wouldn't have gotten that money yeah no
[ __ ] it wasn't a choice between them I
don't care we're never gonna see that it
might as well go to Ukraine send it
how can you send it dude send it back or
send it just send it to them give them
more give them more I'm just kidding we
could always give ourselves more money
like during the pandemic that's what it
seems like dude like let's just [ __ ] are
you talking about print that [ __ ] but
then some people don't want to do that
because then other people get money and
they'd rather see other people not get
it than then get it it's like a constant
like uh it's like a constant poker game
where you're never the chip leader but
you can just stick around long enough to
be at the poker table yeah that's all we
can do you know what I mean and then you
might hit a big once you might [ __ ]
bankrupt but you buy back in yeah you
know the greatest poker table in the
world in the [ __ ] world
[Laughter]
so what do you think about
uh you know
the comedy scene here
it's dope dude like um to be honest like
I remember growing up like uh we had
like HBO and show time and stuff and
like I remember seeing like
um
like Chris Rock special I don't was it
like bigger and Blacker or was it
bulletproof I can't remember but one of
the older ones like George Carlin and
like uh just like earlier like you know
Dave Chappelle
um you know you saw those but like you
never think like in a million years like
you're gonna like start going to like
comedy shows because I was like 10 or 11
years old like or like 12 13. most
people don't do it no definitely I don't
understand why not it's so much fun dude
like uh they locked your phone up
like just the break away from the cell
phones almost worth it like alone you
know what I mean but like
um yeah man like you get to see like
it's it's in its truest art form like
you know I'm you know lucky enough to be
cool with some folks and like
get to see the other side of the curtain
you know what I mean and get to see like
the raw moments of people that are
nervous before they go up or people that
are like uh punching stuff up
uh you know right before they go on or
whatever and like I get to see some of
the best of the best go up and do it and
kill it and it's like holy [ __ ] like
this is uh it's a very weird art form it
is dude because like you know I've been
writing songs and playing songs for a
[ __ ] minute and like
you know you just kind of start coming
into your own in like that seventh
eighth year you know of like yeah that's
whenever I started really seeing like I
was good enough to get gigs and good
enough to work
but I wasn't doing anything that was
like setting myself apart from anybody
else
so like
the second like I'd say like that
seventh and eighth year whenever I you
know kind of like changed up the The
Styling of music I was playing it just
started playing what I was into we
started seeing success you know what I
mean so it's like you get to see what
works what doesn't work what people
change they go out there and you know it
works for them now you know yeah I mean
there's a lot of similarities we'll say
before this dude the only comedy [ __ ]
that I saw dude I went to on a date
party in in Austin and I saw uh it was
like in college and I saw Larry Wilmore
dude and he was [ __ ] so goddamn funny
dude he was hilarious and like it was
like a bunch of college kids like you
know it's obviously like they rented out
the comedy club or whatever for that
show or whatever for one of the shows
that he had there for the the day or
whatever and he was just like lighting
people on fire in the audience and it
was hilarious and uh then I'd seen like
one of the other things I've gone to is
like Esther Follies which is like some
improv stuff yeah he was like
yeah it's like it's not like you know I
guess like you see like Whose Line Is It
Anyway growing up and you had like Wayne
Brady and uh you know Drew Carey yeah
dude that was like you know really funny
improv but then like you go see improv
that sucks it's like oh golly
you know improv that sucks is like so
bad because there's so much effort
it's not like it's not like stand-up
where it's just oh this is just talking
they're like acting it out there's
multiple people there everyone's trying
it's like come on it's like a dry dry
starting an engine right it's like uh
well it gets it's painful because if you
don't connect to what they're doing
right immediately and they're sitting
there like acting in front of you and
you're just like oh this is so much
worse than somebody just saying
something that's not funny or like but
when it hits it's amazing it's Whose
Line Is It Anyway you know what I mean
because it just puts you in those most
ridiculous places sometimes you have
comedians that are super animated and
it's appropriate you know what I mean
like they have like they're really good
at making sounds they're like they're
really good at like uh you know uh like
would you like staging blocking I guess
like you know they're good at like
setting stuff up with their body and
their like making like you know just
adding layers to their [ __ ] set like
that yeah sometimes it works out you
know yeah
um but yeah I mean I think it's great
that uh you're like seeing the comedy
because then watching like grunk it's
like whenever I was younger I saw all
that and then like now that like I'm
older and I get to like kind of hang
around the scene like you get to meet
folks like uh
you know like Molly's really [ __ ]
good and will Montgomery's [ __ ]
hilarious and like uh you know Dave
Lucas like you get to see all these guys
that are kind of like coming into their
exactly well they're also you learn
maybe how you could do it in a way that
would you know be honest to you and
funny
right it's like I well I I did I try to
not be funny when I'm around any you
know I'm like let like try to not be the
funniest guy in the room but uh like
like you get to see like you know where
y'all are coming into y'all zone now too
you know like coming in like you know
you're headlining your own shows now
you're headed out to you said the Vegas
and Utah yeah this weekend get your
tickets if you can right now thank you
but um yeah dude like it's [ __ ]
really cool dude and like um like it's
been built like it you know I'd say like
within like a year and a half two years
like since the pandemic yeah like it
happened quick yeah and like big guns
certain just set up shop right that's
all it takes well they've also got that
[ __ ] iron uh Dome around them of like
uh people that sniff out like [ __ ]
and like everyone's really chilled
things out the thing about the comedians
is that we're always hanging out we're
always going up on the same shows
hanging out like I feel like musicians
uh uh I don't know maybe they they hang
out a lot too
well it's like you never get to go to
like your favorite musicians like show
because you're always gigging but like
whenever you are in a festival or like
you are into like their town or
something and y'all are off like right
but we are doing short sets because it's
harder to do comedy for three hours
that's [ __ ] impossible well that's
not impossible I've heard this video
yeah you guys are like the main thing
for that three hours but for a comedy
show that's 10 15 minute sets at the
comedy store right and they got like 20
30 comedians all bumping elbows I think
it's a very social scene and like coming
up doing open mics I guess musicians
hang out too but there's like a premium
on hanging out in comedy because it's
about the humor yeah right it's like oh
you're good at comedy let's see it off
stage right
it's like well also it's like um you
know in a working scenario too like if
you're going out on the road with like a
band and you know
you want to make sure that you can
[ __ ] hang out with the person at
breakfast in the morning or like because
if you're on the road these [ __ ]
people forever and like you can't
[ __ ] stand them a week and a half
into it like that yeah it doesn't matter
how much you get along with yeah that'll
make their experience so much better
right and so it's like you know you
always like you know you try and be you
know like a good band mate you try and
like have a good hang you know you know
trying like to not be like
you don't like over talk over people and
you don't want to like uh be like
overbearing you know what I mean just
try and be very like just yeah you don't
talk too much or too little because
that's creepy you're just sitting there
right it's like you want to contribute
but don't like lead the dance I guess
you know it's like you kind of like know
your role in the uh in the hierarchy or
like the Schism there but like
there's a
yeah there's like an art to it dude like
there's people that are so [ __ ]
talented dude but they're so [ __ ]
shitty of a hang it's like I would never
call you in a [ __ ] you know I'd
rather have the kid that [ __ ] like
can play than like have like the [ __ ]
guy that you can't hang out with that
you know you've got to [ __ ] well if
you can't it usually shows like a
weakness in your game like you're too
arrogant you're all full of yourself you
can't learn to hang with others so it's
like yeah there's like it's gonna yeah
it's like some fake [ __ ] are you putting
up like a uh like a front yeah because
like people are trying to get along if
you can't get along with someone that's
trying to get along with you you're
[ __ ] yeah yeah you've also gotta like
[ __ ] like you know don't just talk
just to talk somebody comes to be with
like the [ __ ] weather [ __ ] I'm like
uh the weather [ __ ] not with the weather
[ __ ] again yes dude I'll catch myself
doing that and all like
that's something you'd be like oh you
want to talk about weather [ __ ]
what do you think about this cumulus
cloud in the low front yeah what do you
think about this low pressure
[Laughter]
I mean yes if someone's like [ __ ]
and they talk about the weather then
it's like oh that's cute but if
someone's like you see it in their eyes
they're like hey how about the weather
then it's like oh you want something
else this is like a game to you you
think you're smarter than me right well
it's like also it's like a you know what
did you want to talk about
like yeah like weather's the opener this
is what you do with people you better
come at me with some [ __ ] like fire
now
like this better be the best
freestyling that wouldn't be bad
that would also be like all of college
was like white people getting drunk and
rapping
yeah it's fun you don't need to be good
at it you really don't you just gotta
talk in a weird way but yeah I mean uh
I I think like some people are like oh a
person what can I get out of this person
just normal small talk it's like there's
so much more you could get out of
someone and you're just it's like taking
a Ferrari like 20 miles per hour yeah
they like assume that you're limited in
what your uh capable of speaking of
maybe or maybe so what's your favorite
color
it's like that's funny the kindergarten
Icebreaker would be the [ __ ] yeah you
want to be my best friend yeah
that'd be this [ __ ] yeah I mean there's
some [ __ ] like uh sometimes people
are so bad at conversation they become
good at conversation I think I guess
that's the idea with these things like
you know podcast conversation like you
know talking and listening like
um oh [ __ ] Are there moments where like
you've like bombed in a green room and
you're like
I gotta take [ __ ]
well I was in The Green Room with some
high-powered executive people in comedy
and I uh I took mushrooms and I had like
this feeling in the back of my throat
It's gotta clear your throat and yeah
and then I started gagging
and then I like ran out of the I was
like mid
mid uh dry heave and everyone heard it
like that a weird noise coming out of my
mouth and yeah that was embarrassing I
just went to the bathroom and then came
back a little like 30 minutes later
so you had to explain to these
high-level execs
I'm not sick it's just these mushrooms
they do it to me yeah whenever I'm on
mushrooms I like I'll yawn a lot like if
you see me [ __ ] your jaw
you start yawning dude like uh yonica
you know
yeah
Anonymous yeah
[Music]
on Drexler
um Drexler uh but yeah I uh
yeah I love conversation I love people
that are bad at it I just hate people
that think that they're gonna if you
think you're good at it then you're bad
at it but then it's like you have to
have some sort of confidence in it and I
think everyone has a different level of
that that they appreciate looks like a
dance you know learning how to like you
know lead and follow you know yeah
there's people that are [ __ ] probably
you've been on a podcast or probably
like had a conversation with somebody
who's like
has like pre-planned [ __ ] bullet
points in their head that they're just
waiting to [ __ ] fire out yeah and
like they're not like listening you know
to like what you're saying almost so
it's like your conversation is kind of
like
doesn't really get going almost you know
until like eventually finally like
somehow or another you're like you're
[ __ ] conversation catches up with
what the [ __ ] they're trying to like
push out there or something you know
yeah sometimes they're just like
not in a place to listen to people
they're like people are not worth
contributing they're not contributing
anything worthy right so then they just
tune it out and then it's not like
you're creating something like back and
forth it's just like they're on a path
and you can either follow or like do
your own thing and then it's like two
people having monologues at each other
right well I feel like it's kind of like
whenever stuff kind of like you know
like if you're listening to a podcast
and like they don't really kind of start
like getting onto a certain subject the
guy who's like you know the leader of
the podcast would be like all right well
and like try and like Circle or like
draw them back in you know like kind of
like Wrangle them back into like the
conversation and like the person that's
trying to like push their not
necessarily it's not like a an agenda or
something like that but it's like maybe
they're nervous and that you know their
knee-jerk reaction is to try and
dominate a conversation to try and like
seem confident you know what I mean so
they [ __ ] totally [ __ ] it up yeah you
know what I mean like there's been also
there's moments like that whenever you
get nervous and like uh like you're in a
green room or something like that or
you're at a festival and like you
[ __ ]
you mouth off I'm not like mouth off or
whatever but like you know you say
something that you think is gonna land
or that you think it's gonna be funny I
don't think it's a joke and you're just
like
it's like oh [ __ ] how's that guy yeah
like it sounds weird right coming out
yeah man like uh we were playing at the
House of Blues
and we were hanging out in the green
room with the uh the headliner and
everyone was like kind of like telling
jokes and uh [ __ ] uh the headliners
like in the middle of like telling a
joke and uh we're partying and stuff so
we were like having a good time and all
of a sudden like before he can like say
the punchline [ __ ] Sam like shouts it
and so like the [ __ ] energy is like
vacuumed out of there oh yeah we just
wanted to hear from his voice yeah we
all just like look at Sam like what the
[ __ ] did you just do dude
it was [ __ ] really funny the guy was
like uh hey man what's the difference
between a a garbanzo uh garbanzo being a
chickpea and everyone's like what and
Sam just goes I've never had a chick pee
on my face
chickpea on my face yeah someone said
that on kill Tony I was like that sounds
like a street joke it is very much so a
street joke chickpea yeah it's a funny
word garbanzo bean sounds like a slur
yeah so
he's never had a chickpea on his face
wouldn't it be funnier if he did have a
chickpea on his face like he's bragging
about that would probably be way funnier
but it's harder to do it well see that's
the comedian in you though you know what
I mean like you could take a like a
centennial old joke and give it a little
Salt Bay action how you got it something
well I'm just thinking like why are you
going out of your way to tell people
that you don't do something yeah you
don't get your face pissed on yeah yeah
the funnier Lane is definitely getting
peed on yeah
but yeah
um you don't want to like be like I
don't do things oh tell me more about
things you don't do right but yeah
that's my pet peeve in conversation but
yeah maybe I think the reason why it's
like that is because it works better as
a flow I've never had a chickpea on my
face
it's just funnier than I've I've had a
chickpea on my face
because it just sort of that's sort of a
question yeah it's like a statement at
that point I've had a chickpea on my
face yeah whoa now that's kind of
[ __ ] hilarious if you say it like
that I had a chickpea on my face yeah
because it's almost so [ __ ] funny
because people expect you to say
what everyone knows yeah yeah but then
you say that that's like
you could go with I've
never had a garbanzo
I've never had garbanzo on my face
and then they'd have to go through the
extra step of thinking well have you had
a chickpea on your face oh wait that
means chickpea
but anyways
uh yeah I mean I love Green Room hangs I
love you know making mistakes
because it's like this isn't important
that's the thing about green rooms it's
like it's not the show but it is
preparing for the show oh definitely so
it is important but it's not I'd almost
rather eat [ __ ] on a stage than in a
green room
you know the people that like really saw
it that like out there like I could bomb
in front of a crowd that's fine but like
if I have to go back to like the green
room and like the heads in there you're
right there's nowhere to go with like so
like there's this uh this is dude uh
[ __ ] uh his name's uh Mike McClary
he's [ __ ] awesome he's a really funny
[ __ ] he's a great I mean he's a
Godfather of [ __ ] Red Dirt music but
uh like he's really [ __ ] funny dude
and uh I can't remember who it was but
uh showed him
was saying that there uh somebody was
opening for him and uh the headliner
like got off State and the opener got
off stage and was walking into the green
room and was like went over to the
headliner to like go get like their
roses like hey man like thanks for
having us out blah blah blah and Mike
looked at him goes yeah man you killed
it the vibe
I'm just like totally rugged these kids
it's [ __ ] so funny dude like that
shit's funny and obviously he's just
[ __ ] around because no Headliners
ever listened to the [ __ ] openers
anyway but like you know what you mean
the vibe and the in the room are you
[ __ ] The Green Room no in the and um
yeah yeah like you killed the vibe like
you killed it the vibe uh yeah yeah but
he they could tell he was joking yeah I
mean maybe not like shirt of knew you
know what I mean yeah like oh that was
the best you could do yeah like it was
just it's funny ribbing like seniority
like mob mob [ __ ]
right no no I don't even say like mob
[ __ ] but it's just like [ __ ] like
just cracking jokes you know what I mean
yeah keeping it loose busting balls you
know because you're done what you feel
doesn't matter anymore no definitely and
it's also it's like don't take yourself
too serious where you can't laugh at
some [ __ ] like that you know what I mean
no yeah that shit's [ __ ] funny I've
definitely had moments like that where
I've gone out there and eaten a big old
[ __ ] sandwich and thought that I [ __ ]
crushed and went to the Green Room yeah
it's like Jesus Christ
so yeah did they actually do bad
did the person who I mean probably did
there's so many bands out there like uh
you know it's like there's a very select
you know I'm not like tooting my own
horn you know there's just kind of
there's probably like there's not very
many touring successful comedians I'm
sure there's a [ __ ] a lot of them
it's a skill you can either do it or you
can't right so like there's either like
there's probably a lot of comedians but
there's not a lot of touring and working
comedians like yourself like you work
yourself up to this Echelon so there's
like a lot of bands out there but
there's not like a lot of like [ __ ]
touring bands selling tickets and like
really like you know Making Waves and
stuff like that like that that takes a
[ __ ] it takes a lot you know it takes
[ __ ]
what we've been talking about you know
this whole time eating the [ __ ] sandwich
and you know learning from your mistakes
and working you know yeah
um
yeah I love the life you know it's
better than nine to five and it's more
like dangerous because you could lose
your livelihood at any moment yeah man
you could get canceled at any any point
in time
no yeah man but also it's like you know
fortune favors those who are [ __ ]
willing to to take a risk but also like
you know opportunity favors those that
are willing to [ __ ] work for it you
know someone's got to do it right like
if you took a shovel and [ __ ] started
digging and didn't stop like you'd
eventually get [ __ ] somewhere you
know what I mean and like along the way
you're hitting Milestones you thought
nobody'd [ __ ] think that you'd ever
dig to so like you just got some better
use of your time than just treading
water in the corporate world right dude
making some other [ __ ] Rich dude
that's just lame dude you've got damn
you're a communist well dude I can't
stand the uh well I mean dude we [ __ ]
need drones don't get me wrong you need
people like that to make the world go
round dude but like you don't have to if
you're driven enough and [ __ ] really
hate that [ __ ] enough then you'll figure
out how to monetize what the [ __ ] you
like doing and you'll make a living
doing it like you don't don't you make a
life not a living you know what I mean
like [ __ ] you can not everybody's set
up to be [ __ ] Joe or set up to be
Hans or set up to be Tony sometimes
you've got to [ __ ] have some mid you
know people but you're oh we make more
of those now than we need we we
automatically we've got to kill those
people we just create those people out
of instinct right well I mean I just
feel like people gotta also like have a
grip on reality on what they want to get
out of it and like yeah you can [ __ ]
legit play 200 shows a year like an
acoustic show like you could play 200
300 shows a year and [ __ ] pay a
mortgage and drive a car and you know
you don't you may not be out touring and
selling on shows Nationwide you may not
like be like you know like this massive
person but you can you know you can do
whatever the [ __ ] you can live a life
doing what you want to do but you've got
to figure out how and be willing to to
get there you know yeah I think it's not
easy and it's easier in some other
places was like and you know if you're
from middle class background oh
seriously you got to have a starting
point somewhere you know but it's almost
like a
the uh the technology and stuff's coming
along to where like it's kind of helped
bridging that Gap you know yeah like
where people can you know the internet
you know sometimes it's not even the
people's like you know just somebody
performing on the side of the street
some random stranger takes a video of
them and it's not even from their phone
yeah gets posted to somewhere and then
they're picked up you know by somebody
because it was like a viral video you
know yeah it's good when that happens I
think like the technology is great I
just think economically it's not because
if you have all the technology but you
still have to work at McDonald's 40
hours a week you're not going to make as
much yeah that [ __ ] doesn't [ __ ] make
sense you know yeah they're um there's
the system's definitely broken but it's
also there to be [ __ ] gamed like
there's [ __ ] tons of people that like
[ __ ]
you know it's a we live in a really like
weird time and the wild west yeah I do
where it still is like you can get
[ __ ] rich like selling feet picks or
like [ __ ] in a bag and like you can
also get rich
developing a self-driving car you know
or like you can get rich making a song
you know so it's like uh you kind of
gotta like Embrace uh the what you're in
and then kind of change what you want to
change along the way like you know try
and be like if you want to see change
then you gotta [ __ ] you know vote it
in or practice you know in your corner
you know make your corner brighter and
live how you want to live you know yeah
I mean I enjoy doing what I do I just
think like there's a lot of potential
that we're leaving on the table like
that we could be utilizing by just being
like doing some common sense things like
if this was Sim City you'd be like oh
yeah let's just put in a Subway here
right let's get rid of the sewer by the
playground yeah you know that's the
number one indicator of someone getting
out of poverty is if there's public
transit well it is
true dude like do you want to know where
[ __ ] the hood is and I don't mean
this in any bad way but it's like it
doesn't have to be like just like a
really poor poverty-stricken area is
going to be a place that has a liquor
store or a [ __ ] pawn shop and like a
cash check only spot right there yeah
and a [ __ ] Popeyes oh and a ton of
really shitty food options you know what
I mean yeah and like you know no wonder
like [ __ ] nothing ever thrives there
because there's [ __ ] like you know
the it's just set up like that kind of
you know it's a dead end definitely you
only have access to the stores that are
gonna try to [ __ ] you exactly and like
uh you know it's do you see it play out
in real life and like you you get the
older you get the more you see it and
like the more it kind of starts making
sense you're like oh [ __ ] this is like
you know set up to keep people here like
this isn't like uh you know you pull up
into an affluent area and like Frisco or
Plano and there's like a bunch of like
mathnasiums and like [ __ ] you know
what I mean is that just uh chairs and
tables no it's like you have like
Mathnasium they have like yeah chairs
and tables for them to do math
it's like you know like those
alternative schools where like it's like
school after school where like they're
like getting their kids like pre-charged
to go life
wherever they're getting they're
fluffing their children to [ __ ] the
world they've got fluffers and
yeah definitely I think that's like a
big thing and I think that it would be
more meaningful to be successful in a
world where we weren't
shoving half the population down right
well it's also it's like you know that's
how it's all that's been we also live in
a [ __ ] crazy time we're all this
[ __ ] shit's coming out you know yeah
like literally like I want to [ __ ] go
back to high school and get all my
biology courses [ __ ] all my grades
bumped up because half the [ __ ] they're
forcing that much throat now is out the
window these days so like yeah they
should do like a recount or like uh dude
a revisement like how a newspapers have
to correct yeah Rand McNally [ __ ]
redacts all your [ __ ]
but like uh yeah man like if we live in
a crazy time where all this shit's
coming to life like [ __ ] you have
people are talking about aliens and [ __ ]
you know what I mean and then like uh
the government's talking about aliens
and like their deflect declassifying
classified documents and
like we survived a [ __ ] Global
pandemic like this shit's crazy it
almost feels like that was like the
reset that people like you and I needed
to [ __ ] really it really helped me
yeah same here yeah it caught me out of
New York I [ __ ] thrived during that I
did too so some of the gigs I played
were [ __ ] [ __ ] but like I was playing
[ __ ] music I was recording at that
time and like was like planning as soon
as like [ __ ] started to open back up
like hit the ground and try to really
give it the old you know college tracks
of people that don't really want to do
it and the pandemic gave them an excuse
to be like I didn't want to do it
anyways otherwise it would have been
just going on momentum it cut down
everyone who was just faking it it kind
of yeah and also even the playing field
because like you weren't touring but
also Tom Segura was a [ __ ] touring
yeah everyone's not touring yeah no [ __ ]
not touring forever for years I'm an
expert at not touring killing it yeah so
like uh yeah man like it was a good time
for that like I felt like I feel like we
live in a really good [ __ ] time right
now we're like we're gonna see a lot of
change but also like um we're in a time
where we can really set ourselves up for
[ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] we want to do
right now yeah I love it
um I think like
yeah I love that I'm in an interesting
time you know like that Chinese curse
may you live in interesting times it's
like I gotta say in this dude that's
some [ __ ] like backhanded [ __ ]
like yeah dude like like it's not
pleasant on the peasants yeah no [ __ ]
dude it's like telling somebody like hey
have a good day and like you're saying
that while you're walking into your car
and they're like I just asked you for a
dollar most people that see historic
events are not uh
you know are not alive to talk about it
like D-Day or I guess D-Day wasn't that
I imagine if they had [ __ ] Tick Tock
when they were storming the beaches
oh my God
[Laughter]
yeah that'd be [ __ ] crazy but we live
in it now we're like we can see oh yeah
we can see Ukraine Ukraine dude that
shit's crazy bro like watching like uh
people die I get a lot of my unbiased
news on uh like World Star Hip-Hop
and uh you'll see some like War [ __ ] on
there and it like literally seems like
it's out of a [ __ ] video game you see
like a [ __ ]
and they drop out a little [ __ ] yeah
little grenade drone that's all you need
and you just see him [ __ ] look up
like oh I'm [ __ ] yeah it's the
craziest thing ever yeah it's crazy
seeing like people like run around
corners and then get shot it's like
that's all it takes you know it's like I
run around corners all the time
yeah like imagine if like we were like
in a like we don't have to worry about
that you know for the most part you know
I mean there are there are like
shootings in America and stuff like that
but for the most part like [ __ ]
Austin's not in a [ __ ] fight with
Buda where we're [ __ ] shooting
rockets in the [ __ ] Cabela's from you
know like it's been a really [ __ ]
fortunate spot and it's crazy to like
to see like we like
there's videos of the now there's like
cameras there's phones there's the
internet now with those phones and now
you're seeing like you know people were
like you know like the the the
and I'm going to say they're getting
like westernized but you're seeing like
[ __ ] Air Jordans on somebody who's
like in like a full you know get up and
they're throwing [ __ ] lead down the
line you know what I mean they're like
there's like a a video of somebody that
had like this old Houston like plumber
or something like that I don't know how
it happened but
there's like a a Toyota [ __ ] Tundra
with like a Houston number and like a
business on it and it's got a turret
it's like overseas that's hilarious
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah we're just
sending all our [ __ ] over there [ __ ]
sending it send it to you hey we're
making money we can sell sell this [ __ ]
and make money off of it
arbitraging pickup trucks Arbitrage dude
that's not the Arbitrage Menage is what
was going on with Sam bankman freed dude
yeah it was [ __ ] some ugly girl a
bunch of them apparently they're all
[ __ ] one another
oh my God can you imagine being a
billionaire and still like [ __ ] the
people that you could only [ __ ] when you
were like in high school that anybody
probably could have anybody that gave
them any ounce of attention it's great
like sometimes I don't know if it's just
me but I'll be in public and I'll see
people and I'll just be like [ __ ]
gross yeah like those people go have sex
and that [ __ ] grosses me out and like
I saw all those [ __ ] people and I was
like [ __ ] gross like if you had to be
or you have sex with dude imagine like
the person who had to clean that house
weekly that poor lady whoever they had
that cleaning lady Accutane Accutane
[ __ ] latex water-based lubricant I
heard there's over 10 000 pounds of
water-based lubricant there I don't know
what to do
they were having sex orgies
and gross because that'd be like I feel
the same I'd laugh about that the same
way if I found out that they were like
gangbangers like not like that but like
if I found out that they were like
like had guns and like drugs and [ __ ]
like you've nerds like cosplays
like that sex is hard it's not just
about having money or being
you know I guess being good looking
really helps
I think that's the only thing that
really helps but yeah I mean even if
you're rich it's not like you just have
the ability to [ __ ] anyone there's still
like a lot that goes into it that you're
just not gonna pass the [ __ ] smell
tests from hot girls
there's like a different level of hot
where like you don't even at that point
you're not even talking about
personality you're just talking about
being able to like have sex with the
person there's money that like buys that
you know what I mean like the person
that has the personality isn't the
[ __ ] the one that you want to date
the one you want to marry isn't the one
that you like the billionaire can
[ __ ] fly her out and like [ __ ] her
like that's not the one you know what I
mean yeah so like I think that there is
like there's money to that but like do
you think Sam bankman freed was more
into the emotional authenticity no that
[ __ ] nerd he could have been banging
anybody he wanted to but for some reason
it's not scary it's like a [ __ ]
Warren Buffett eating cheeseburgers it's
just like you could have amazing food
but you're stuck [ __ ] the six
well he had like five of them yeah so I
think that kind of drove him kind of
like that was kind of it like oh these
girls want to [ __ ] me
you know when like in reality it's just
sad because like we're all taught that
there is a Promised Land if you work
hard enough you can [ __ ] pretty girls
and like he did he got all the success
that you could ever get and he's still
like there's still something that's
keeping him
[ __ ] hot girls
dude I don't know like who this guy is
banging or whatever but uh there's
another comedian that's like popped up
on on my radio and I really tuned in and
like started listening to his [ __ ] stavi
stavrosy baby dude yeah what the [ __ ]
that dude's so goddamn funny and I I'm
pretty sure he [ __ ] like all the time
yeah and like that's okay so do you
think it's because he was defrauding
everyone he had billions of dollars no
but I think if you have billions of
dollars he would not be [ __ ] a room
of sixes I think he would still be like
he's got the mentality of a [ __ ]
Tyrant so he would have like [ __ ]
like but he wasn't
he was being an evil person and not even
enjoying the benefits of it
yeah because he I think that he was like
broken enough inside where just anybody
who gave him attention which happened to
be like those girls like he didn't tap
it like I feel like he would would be
yeah like he doesn't need the uh the
Ponzi scheme yeah to he's more an artist
he's emotionally honest and he's
authentic but I think that's what it is
dude yeah people girls can smell it on
him so you think like hot girls did the
world of service by not [ __ ] this guy
they could tell do you think there was
like uh I don't think he had the balls
to do it
the most dudes the first time their
[ __ ] bank account probably gets over
like 10 grand they probably [ __ ] a
hooker you know what I mean like like if
they've got money and they're single and
they're [ __ ] like you know whatever
they probably would [ __ ] a hooker like
sex work is becoming so common these
days it's not even like probably that
big of a factor these days in their head
you know so like that they're not even
thinking about that but like that dude
is just a [ __ ] nerd man so I think he
was just the end of people being Hindu
yeah you I don't think he yeah I don't
think he I think he got what he deserved
like if you're defrauding people
whatever happened did you guys sexually
he's getting what he deserves uh oh yes
sexually for sure yeah I don't know I I
think uh I think he might be in jail
but yeah I mean like I think that's
wonderful that's like wow like women
have like they're like a self-cleaning
organism they have like radar about this
[ __ ] they can just sniff it out right no
yeah they definitely got like a uh I
think they can tell like
kind of like off like uh you know like
your your body language and like
just wear your Vibes right where you
steer conversations off of like you know
well also if they're just rejecting
everyone all the time a broken clock is
right twice a day
so I think like women don't [ __ ] enough
you heard that
I don't know maybe I'm just an incel at
heart but yeah I just feel like it's
like there's there's like there's not a
lot of action going on and it's like
really
hurting Humanity
that's why there's shooters
they can't handle their [ __ ] right
because they don't have the 499 to send
them private messages on only fans so
they don't get the attention they need
yeah it's important a man without a
female would need Universal basic income
to fund only fans accounts for people
that cannot afford them so we can reduce
the stress levels on the poverty
stricken America my name is Ellis
Bullard I'm here to ask for your vote
ah
well yeah I don't uh I I think there's
reasons why women don't [ __ ] a lot of
men I think it's because like a lot of
men are economically depressed what's
the mindset dude like between like with
dudes it's total [ __ ] 180 like I'm
the [ __ ] man if I'm out there
stroking where it's like if you're a
chick and you're out there
getting laid you're [ __ ] you know for
some people's mindsets your value goes
down whereas like the men's goes up you
know what I mean well yeah the only
person that really knows that is the
girls themselves I think it's an
internalized shame and every dude that
tells 10 dudes that tells 10 dudes that
he [ __ ] her you know
yeah the dudes are part of it too
um
yeah I just think uh I think at this
point it's like women are internalized
like the sexual oppression and they're
like the they're like the you know the
people that carry the torch for like
Victorian era sex practices like I would
love to move forward and have polyamory
and like different types of love as
opposed to just monogamous white picket
fence marriage and that's like the
standard that everyone judges
relationships on like if you're not
ready for this right when I first meet
you then I don't even want to develop a
relationship because that means you're
not respecting me and I just feel like
that's an unrealistic standard it's not
economically feasible uh why don't we
just be honest and in the moment instead
of like having all these years of like
weird sexual uh you know like yeah so
you're down to incorporate but you want
to have some staff you want to have some
employees around the business is what
you're saying I mean I'm not greedy I am
happy with just one girl but it's like
it's not realistic it's not what anyone
wants girls don't even want that right
girls want to have sex with other people
I'm sure
um but yeah I mean I will do monogamy
it's just like not something that I
think is like
uh it's like I'm going through the
motion like oh here's me going to
college like I'm doing monogamy
getting my first tattoo
I'm gonna do it no yeah dude that's
[ __ ] I mean there is some truth to
that man but honestly I feel like some
people you know are wired for that like
um you know I didn't date my girlfriend
now like I didn't date in college or in
high school you know so like
I like was having a [ __ ] blast and
like being a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] up
until like you know she was like calling
me on my [ __ ] and was like yo like
what the [ __ ] are you doing
and so I was like you know I woke up he
was like yo like
definitely like I flew super close to
the Sun [ __ ] had a good time you know
what I mean I'm gonna try something
different for a while and it's [ __ ]
really good for me so like you know I
think it works for some people but I
definitely agree with you like [ __ ]
yeah dude like [ __ ] the internet's
made it [ __ ] tough to [ __ ] be
monogamous because it's made
relationships Expendable you've got
[ __ ] uh
3 000 people like in your photo 25 35 50
of them are females and like let's say
like a percentage of them are attractive
like you've got options you know what I
mean it's like living like back in the
day you didn't have any of that so like
you kind of fixed what was going on or
whatever but it's just a different or
you were stuck with someone that or you
were that man you're the Milkman back in
the day you're the mailman yeah the only
person that they can see Tinder in real
life yeah right they're going up right
to your door
that's a risky move [ __ ] someone's
wife in their own home that shit's crazy
to me and I guess like I I it took me to
like
to like get older do I pick up on it but
there's been like so many times where
like I've like have been like my like oh
those people were trying to [ __ ] me like
I need I'm glad I got out of there yeah
like what the [ __ ] is going on yeah
sometimes people want to [ __ ] but
they're not in a good position to [ __ ]
and could lead to your death
oh no yeah if they're in a relationship
or something
and it's and then you know they've got
the uh it was a crime committed out of
passion yeah
I'll never find myself in that position
again
dude so you got talked into it you took
the bait
took the cheese yeah she was flaunting
it out there and that rat trap yeah came
on down
which uh trick as old as time dude you
mean for real right now this happened
me no oh [ __ ] dude I was thinking you
were telling me like you went home with
some lady and like her husband walked in
no oh yeah that's the worst case
scenario that's R Kelly Trapped in the
Closet
[ __ ] uh yeah it's a crazy [ __ ]
that's nuts yeah that's yeah that's how
people die do you ever get approached by
couples yeah that's [ __ ] funny that's
awesome where's it uh like is it more
prevalent one state than the other
uh usually in the midwest it's more
the flyover states dude yeah they got
just enough internet to be super horny
but nowhere to go do it yeah they got a
wife and not much else golly that's
something
that's wild have you uh been
propositioned by couples
um not like outright but like I was
saying like as I got older now that I
got thought back on him it was like oh
no [ __ ] she kept on trying to get me to
go get a drink with her over there
because she you know was like oh [ __ ]
like what and uh well I mean dude there
was one chick and it wasn't me but it
was our band mate and um
she was like giving Adam the eyes all
night and she was with this dude and
like this is so weird she's like like so
like [ __ ] like she's trying to bang
somebody up here and uh she's like you
know we're packing up and loading up and
her and Adam like exchanged phone
numbers or whatever and she's texting
Adam she's like God [ __ ] my boyfriend
and like he's like yeah [ __ ] him like
that's this sucks and she was like no
like come to our hotel and [ __ ] my
boyfriend and he's like what the [ __ ]
yeah he's like a hard sell right yeah
you gotta do this also open up with the
lady and then be like hey there's also a
guy that was like the [ __ ] ultimate
like [ __ ] like rabbit out of the Hat
type thing he's like
whoa you were fishing for somebody to go
bang your boyfriend that's crazy yeah
but they're out there and I respect yeah
yeah that's that scratches an itch for
some people you know whatever float your
boat you know yeah well you want to call
it yeah man it's a good time yeah thanks
for coming man yeah of course dude
uh